Wednesday season 2 is shaping up to be
huge with a big mystery about who's
behind those threatening messages the
possible return of Miss Thornhill and
principal Weems and perhaps a secret new
master controlling the hide yippikai
movie lovers I'm Jan and in this video
I'll be explaining everything you can
look forward to in the second season of
Wednesday spoilers ahead of course so
take care Laurel aka Miss Thornhill the
evil mastermind behind everything in
season one ends up in a really bad way
by the final episode covered in bees and
with Wednesday's boot coming down to
stomp her in the face many people have
assumed this means the villainous school
teacher is dead but I don't think that's
the case and I'm pretty certain Netflix
will want to bring Christina Ritchie
back to the show there's also the fact
that we never see what happens to her
body after Wednesday's Stomp and a great
comment by movie lover Mojo litical
points out that crack Stone's ring will
probably have something to do with
Laurel's return as the evil resurrected
Pilgrim burn and up the ring on his
finger fell to the ground and there was
a deliberate slow motion close-up shot
of the Ring a signal that it will surely
play a part in the future at the end she
was also lying on the ground not far
from where crack Stone's ring fell so if
we assume she survived and crawled off
she could have easily spotted the ring
taking it with her the ring features a
kraken a legendary sea monster wrapping
its tentacles around a ship this feels
like a hint that the villainous Laurel
and Tyler are part of an even bigger
monstrous plot directed at Wednesday and
perhaps the entire Adams Family or
Laurel Gates and Tyler just pawned in a
bigger game a character who appeared to
be a lot more dead by the end of season
1 was principal Weems who was injected
with deadly nightshade Poison by Laurel
after she and Wednesday confronted her
now tons of you have said you really
aren't ready for Larissa Weems to be
gone and I do think there's a decent
possibility that Weems secretly survived
given Weems and Wednesday knew about
Laurel's predilection for chemical
manipulation Weems might have consumed
an antidote earlier to counteract the
poison Weems is also a shapeshifter so
it's possible she cast an illusion to
show herself dying but in reality she
was okay now I'm not saying that Weems
is alive for sure as it can Chief in a
character's sacrifice if a death is too
easily reversed in a movie or TV show
however we never saw a funeral for Weems
like we did with the dead mer and
Gwendolyn Christie said the following in
an interview about season two we haven't
seen her put in the ground have we I
feel like Larissa Weems would not really
be prepared to entertain or be dominated
by anything as commonplace as death the
last few moments of the finale leave us
with a big question about who could be
behind the threatening messages on
Wednesday's new phone although I expect
Laurel to be returning I doubt it's her
but it is likely to be the main villain
for season two so let's run through the
likeliest candidates a great comment by
movie lover fabulous Sumas says it will
turn out to be Xavier's father a
character we haven't yet met but who was
mentioned multiple times in season one
my dad's a psychic Vincent Thorpe my
brother's his number one fan watch this
Vegas Special so many times I'm
surprised it's not imprinted on his
eyeballs Xavier's dad appears to be
quite a cold character and uninterested
in his son he didn't show up on parents
weekend or when he was arrested and he's
uncaring about some of the difficulties
that Xavier experiences with his powers
my father thinks that my mental health
is a PR problem that he needs to manage
Vincent could have some dark secrets
from his former time but Nevermore that
he'd prefer were kept quiet so if he
discovered Wednesday has been snooping
around he might have decided to scare
her off further investigations as
Xavier's dad it wouldn't be too
difficult for him to get access to his
son's phone to get Wednesday's number
and send her the threatening text thanks
to his Fame he might be recruited as a
new principal to replace Weems and given
that Xavier's family already met the
Adams family in the past it was my
Godmother's funeral apparently she was
friends with your grandmother it'd be
interesting to see how he
was Gideon the morning song cult leader
mentioned by Gabrielle Bianca's mum
Gideon said you'd resist you think he'd
give a damn about some single mom or her
daughter if we weren't Sirens I think
the cult may have designs on Jericho and
its inhabitants for example we saw how
Bianca's mother convinced Lucas to
download The Cult self-help app just in
the weekend she came to visit although
Bianca later persuaded him to ditch it I
think morning song may try to recruit
more normies from the town and perhaps
even never more students who with their
powers and abilities could be a way of
boosting the cult and its influence they
may already have some nefarious secret
activities they're engaged in at the
Academy or in the town and might be
trying to scare off Wednesday from
snooping around any further with the
threatening messages a possible
character we have met who could be the
stalker is Yoko the vampire as many of
you've pointed out indeed Yoko was name
dropped quite a few times but didn't get
many lines so I think that she and
perhaps the vampires as a whole might
get more focus in the second season but
why would Yoko hold a grudge against
Wednesday well a smallish reason might
be how Enid went to room share with Yoko
after she fell out with Wednesday and
they seemed to really hit it off Hugo
and I are so in synced that she's
begging me to be her new roomie but
later Ina dumped Yoko to room again with
Wednesday a more significant reason
though might be that Yoko has some
history with Wednesday's mother Morticia
as apparently many of the vampires that
Nevermore have been there for a very
long time those are the things AKA
vampires some of them have literally
been here for decades the sheriff is
another existing character with reasons
to dislike Wednesday he was already
suspicious of her in the first episode
because of his history with her family
I'm gonna keep my eye on you he might
also resent her for exposing his son
Tyler as a hide and given his job he
could probably find out her number to
send her the messages another
possibility is Kent the siren guy he was
something in the face by thing and about
whom Wednesday didn't hide what she
thought in front of the other
nightshades when she explained how she
discovered their secret meeting room I
thought we'd just snapped twice well
aren't you the brightest in the bunch
there's also Lucas although he turned
good by the end thanks to Bianca he and
his mates have an antagonistic history
with Wednesday and she fought them after
they harassed her at the coffee shop
it's a long shot but another possibility
is that Wednesday's stalker is the jock
from her former High School who bullied
her brother Pugsley he might have
tracked her down in Jericho and is
looking for revenge for the piranhas in
the swimming pool the showrunners have
already confirmed that although the
series is focused around Wednesday they
do plan to bring back the rest of The
Addams Family in season two some fun
ideas are that Pugsley could attend
Nevermore and Morticia could even take
over as principle for the missing Weems
given the former principles animosity to
Morticia this could be really
interesting especially if Weems turns
out to be still alive Uncle Fester will
surely be back too and there were many
teasers for another cousin it making an
appearance next season via the portraits
of Ignatius it in the basement of The
Nightshade Society but just before
Wednesday returns to Nevermore could we
also get some time where she goes to see
Enid in San Francisco I can pretty much
guarantee fog and drizzle every day
sounds tempting the very final shot of
the Season sees a chained up Tyler being
taken away but then hiding out into his
monster form an interesting detail that
another of our movie lovers points out
here is that Tyler's hiding out happens
just as Wednesday's car is passing the
truck transporting his which could
suggest Wednesday is his new master if
it were the case the best explanation I
can think of is that Wednesday locking
him up and torturing him inflicted a
trauma that somehow bonded him to her
born of mutation the hide lays dormant
until Unleashed by a traumatic event I
think for Tyler's season 2 Arc he may
seek out his mother who was never
explicitly confirmed to be dead she was
however locked up as a hide and perhaps
he'll find her if he's being taken to
the same facility and I think there
could be a possible Redemption storyline
for him there and if you want to
discover all the amazing details and
Easter eggs you might have missed in
Wednesday like the many Inspirations for
Jenna Ortega's Raven dance tap here to
watch my video on that there's also a
link in the video description so what
are your predictions or what would you
like to see happen in a second season of
Wednesday let me know in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video do
leave a thumbs up I really appreciate it
thanks for enjoying Wednesday with me
and hope you have a marvelous movie
loving week yippee Kai movie lovers